that ain't Snoop Dogg April Fool's nope
did you think it was him
I did not think that was Snoop Dogg I I
was fooled a little bit and then he
opened his mouth and started to talk and
not him what it was the voice the voice
was the dead giveaway which seems to be
the recurring theme with the show
pronounced hi guys I'm Charlie okie I'm
Deidre Behar and we are here to talk all
about the super 9 April Fool's episode
of the masked singer we are here still
at home we are self quarantine but we
want to take a second to tell you we
read all your comments last week we
Charlie and I are so touched by
everything you guys had to say we love
doing this show because of you and
because of the community that we feel we
have with you guessing these wild masks
and who's behind them so we just want to
say thank you and we are here again at
home still being safe we hope you are
too
let's get things started look that thing
started we have a lot of mass to talk
about so let's jump with the elimination
Shania I'm dare to say it was a roaring
one take a look
we have said it since the Super Bowl
Charlie we nailed this one it was Rob
Gronkowski former NFL Pro were you
shocked finally happy right which I need
to point out because we tend to miss
those ones so Keith I think everyone can
agree we knew this was Rob car Kowski he
gave us some very entertaining
performances and I'm happy he made it to
the Super nine but I am NOT shocked to
see him go tonight no I think it was
time to let people with stronger vocals
perhaps some thrive in the Super nine
but again a fun guy I call him the
governor of fun and chaos because that's
what he is and and great job this season
gronckle miss yet I do have to save
Nicole made an interesting guest before
saying Robert Castilla I'm gonna call it
our first reality check of the night
take a look and I'm gonna stick with it
Rob Gronkowski alright I don't know
about Rob gorgonzola over there or Rob
garbanzo bean I'm thinking it could be
because he loves to dance
Joe macaroni from Magic Mike imagine le
oz I mean I think she's hungry she's
guessing all these foods but not quite
Rob's name you know there's an actor on
the show younger his name is Nico
Tortorella and a few of us at et are on
the office we affectionately call him
Nico tortellini because look at all we
feel you sometimes it's just too
challenging to get some of these like
very Italian sounding last names
I loved it though I think she's wild and
funny and garbanzo bean of all I'm into
it yes it's important well let's jump
right into the group a performances they
certainly brought their a-game take a
look
[Applause]
famous behind
[Applause]
I mean this performance from the turtle
who we still think is Jesse McCartney
I think amuro's was good this version of
higher love is my new favorite version
of higher love ever he totally delivered
and and what did you think of the clue
package the clue package was interesting
so tonight we saw something a little
different it was kind of a throwback to
their journey to the super 9 and then we
got one super clue at the end for Jesse
McCartney who we think it is the turtle
we saw him hold up a comic book that
said The Amazing Adventures of shell boy
well Jessica McCartney with a little
research you could find out that he did
the voice-over work for Robin in a
Warner Brothers animated TV series based
on a comic book called Young Justice hmm
looks like you solved that one like I
saw that one what did you think I'm
stage-play oh well we got these onstage
clues which basically helped us
understand who they are not and so the
turtles was I'm not known for just one
thing and if you're a Jesse McCartney
Jesse McCartney fan you know he's saying
he dances he acts he does voiceover work
he's an entrepreneur the guy does a
million things you might know him from a
million different things so I'm sticking
with Jesse McCartney guys I think we
could all stick with Jesse McCartney
except the judges because they have not
guessed him so maybe maybe next week
try harder guys come on I'm jumping
right over to the kangaroo this was an
interesting performance tonight a little
more insight into who we've been
guessing Jordan was 1,000% Jordan woods
let's go right to the clue package there
were a lot of references to things like
you know I feel very vilified by the
kanga rumors and my kangaroo Murr pouch
and all of those types of things and of
course Jordan woods has gone through a
really tough time with all of her drama
with Kylie Jenner and Tristan Thompson I
also thought the song choice tonight was
an interesting choice because it's been
about a year since all that drama
started and we still haven't seen them
make nice kind of shady kangaroo is here
to tell her story and and her story has
been absolutely fascinating to follow on
this show the big super clue though was
we saw the kangaroo holding another
guru and she said all right dolls do you
know who I am now of course the word
dolls is like synonymous with the
Kardashians Chris Scott Courtney hope
they all love using the term dolls so I
have to say that this has got to be
Jordan woods what do you think I'm
sticking with Jordan we haven't heard
the judges gussie yeah and one of the
other guesses that we can now eliminate
is Iggy Azalea we heard the what are you
not pooping I may be a kangaroo but I've
never lived in Australia well Robin has
previously guessed Iggy and he pointed
out tonight they can now scrap that one
because she is from Australia and it's
clearly not her totally different topic
voices become very different every night
well it is all coming back to us now for
Group B who gave us some interesting and
vocally challenging performances take a
look
[Applause]
oh my god unfortunately seen Celine
Dion's tour got cancelled because of
this whole coronavirus outbreak but the
kitty is giving us the Celine covers
that we deserve I love this performance
what did you think I loved it and I
think we're both sticking with our
guests here of Jackie Evancho I know the
kitty has given us the runaround we've
had some struggles guessing her but I'm
confidently saying Jackie tonight after
that super Clio
we saw the Christmas tree from last
season comeback and we heard her say
Christmas is the most wonderful time of
the year well Jackie Evancho has not one
not two but three Christmas albums I
mean she's giving Mariah Carey a run for
the Christmas Queen I'm sticking with
Jackie here I think it's pretty obvious
1,000% tonight's what are you not clue
was I was not dreaming when Robert
Redford helped me to get my very first
role Jackie Evancho is very first role
was in the 2012 movie the company you
keep and Robert Redford has gone on the
record saying he saw her on America's
Got Talent and absolutely had to cast
her in the movie so Jackie Evancho we're
on to you girl we know it's evil next up
we have the last remaining food in the
competition it is the banana who gave us
a very entertaining performance of Sweet
Home Alabama what do you think of that
tonight I mean it was everything I would
want Bret Michaels to give us in her
performance we're sticking with our guns
we think it's crap Michaels um you know
the super clue was a really big giveaway
it was about a mullet and if you know
anything about mullets they were popular
in the 80s they were popular with rock
and roll stars and with country stars
you guys Bret Michaels is all three this
has to be Bret Michaels right
I think the mullet gets it away I'm
gonna have a bullet if I don't get a
haircut
during this self-quarantine all right
there you go business and be what are
you not clue again this one really
helped the judges get rid of some
previous guesses we heard him say that
blue collar has many meaning
but when we say blue-collar he's a funny
guy but not stand-up funny well
previously the judges have gasped Larry
the Cable Guy and Jeff Foxworthy both
who have done stand-up stand-up
comedians
it's not that we could throw them off
the table to stop guessing that it's one
of those stand-up comedians I think
we've heard Larry the Cable guy's name
every single week it's one of those he
needs to come on the show now just
because it's been guest so many times
moving on
jumping over to the Frog listen I know
this is one of your favorite
performances of the night so take it
away it really was the Frog gives me
like level 10 energy and charisma and
pizzazz with every single performance
the superglue tonight though was a
knight in shining armor so I've got two
pieces of evidence for this one check
this out so number one what we first of
all sorry
Bow Wow we think it's bad well we've
said that from the get-go that's taking
the power back to the super clue in Bow
Wow's movie like hype NBA team that's
featured in the film was called the Los
Angeles Knights now piece of evidence
number two is that Bow Wow was
previously signed to Death Row Records
which was co-founded by Suge Knight so
you got cue meaning there how you gonna
fight me on that absolutely tonight
research I fully support both of those
and I think I think they both point to
battle out there let you choose thank
you over to the what do you not clue we
heard him say he's actually not a
trained dancer at all which is shocking
because he's clearly the best dancer in
this competition that's why we love him
it's not surprising I mean Bow Wow got
his start in R&B and hip hop and rapping
and dance was not something we saw him
do early on in his career but it's
something we see him do a lot of now so
I think that makes a lot of sense if he
wasn't necessarily trained in it yes his
videos on Instagram dancing with his
daughter are the cute well we might have
just saw Group C last week but they are
back and better than ever take a look at
the group C performances
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a Jonas Brothers song I love this choice
for the right out look we're getting
more acquainted with our pal
Barry Zito every single week we're still
sticking with with Barry Zito the former
MLB player for the Rhino his super clue
tonight was a slot machine now Barry
Zito he was actually born in Las Vegas
so that makes a lot of sense but if you
remember a few weeks back we saw him
saying a clew package that I performed
for the King or something about
performing firm for royalty well
actually his parents were Vegas
entertainers who performed with Nat King
Cole so we're consent is Barry Zito
evidence one by one by one and I think
this is definitely him I'm proud of us I
know I'm proud that he's not nearly as
tall as we think he is which is
surprising because that costume
obviously looks ginormous especially
next Nick Cannon
but as Bella Thoren pointed out in your
interview with her previously that the
next one was much higher than her actual
head I think it's the same situation for
the Rhino here
I think Barry Zito is still inside that
costume I mean he's six foot two but the
horn and the head out a lot of height
not necessarily where he may be but we
interviewed costume designer marina toy
bina last year and if we know anything
is that these costumes are deceptive eh
it could be the difference between six
inches or even a foot on somebody so I
like your detective work they're
sticking with Barry ZT here
yeah Barry baked ziti yes when we got
onto the astronaut of course he gave us
another out-of-this-world performance I
am sticking with my man Hunter Hayes
here I mean look Hunter Hayes has such a
distinct country voice it's gotta be him
I want to get right into the clue
package we saw this super clue tonight
was a broken record with a globe or a
world on it and as we said actually last
week how do you on the backwards Willy
hit all that trigonometry and arithmetic
and algebra to get to this conclusion
but hunter actually broke the Guinness
World Record for most shows perform
in the most cities in a single day 10
which is pretty mind-blowing when you
think about it a litter of record and I
think the judges pointing it out tonight
- they're like oh it's the Guinness
World Records well guess what Deidre was
a week ahead of you guys and she figured
it out already so props to you for that
one
moving on to on stage we heard him say I
mean again surprising just like the Frog
he's not voiced trained professionally
so that's surprising to hear someone
who's a professional country singer say
that but what we do know is that Hunter
has had major voice complications we
opened up about this to Rolling Stone
and he said recently he did get a vocal
coach to help him fix those issues and
it's something we hear along a lot of
performers to end up realizing they need
to save their boy has he got
professional training so it's not
surprising I'm glad he did what he did
because we not only get more Hunter
Hayes music we now get him on the
massacre which has been so fun
listen this final performer is one of my
favorite she rose to the occasion one of
your favorites I feel like you hardcore
Stan oh I stand the night angel I mean I
love the Frog but I stand the night
angel until the end when she goes home
mark my words I will cry he might win I
mean listen I want her to win but if she
goes home I will cry I'll be there to
control you thank you virtually yes oh
yes practice social distancing everybody
what did you think of the night angel
super close uh Joey was a tricycle and
she even said you guys wanted an easy
clue well I'm not gonna give you an easy
clue look quite simply the tricycle
represents the number three kandi
Burruss of The Real Housewives of
Atlanta who we believe this is she has
three kids I think it has to be her and
another meaning of the tricycle the
whole try thing kandi Burruss is so many
things she's a reality star she's a
businesswoman she's a singer and a
songwriter I mean that has to work right
I agree and listen she won up to triple
threat on the stage she said I'm not
just a voice I'm a mogul
I meant mogul is a big word to throw out
there but like you said
singer/songwriter reality star she owns
a restaurant she has a makeup line she
even owns an adult toy line I mean the
woman has every business venture taken
care of
get it girl bring team I'm sure exactly
and our co-worker Brice sander key is
also the Real Housewives expert he is
gonna help us out tonight with the
masked singer ringer because he actually
spoke to kandi who addressed the rumors
of her being on the show take a look
everybody and their brother thinks your
linen twine they thought it was me they
thought it was me I don't know a lot of
people sound like me
do you watch the messenger okay can you
do a British accent for me me yeah the
character that everyone thinks you are
talks in a British accent so I just
wanted to see how to line it up
I have not that's what I wanted to see
if you could do one all right always
have to keep watching and see maybe if
you get unmasked or if it's somebody who
just sounds a lot like you I mean I'll
be watching jobs are watching it too
listen I mean we've heard people say it
before we heard Patti LaBelle say it
we've heard every every contestant on
this show have to kind of lie about
their identity what do you think of her
answer ETS Jordan woods about this
earlier this season as well and they all
have the same response watch it like
they play so lovably and adorably dumb
but I can't wait to throw that interview
in her face when we finally unveil that
it is Queen kandi Burruss well we are
finally now down to our super 8 what do
you think of the contestants moving
forward it who's your frontrunner I mean
my frontrunner I'm gonna stick with the
turtle I just can't get enough voice but
I think a very close second could be the
night angel or the Frog what do you
think I listen like I said I stand that
I angel I love everything about her but
I'm also gonna throw the frog in there
just because of the performance I mean
he really brings the value with the
dancing the singing everything on that
stage it's just unstoppable what about
the turtle though justice for justice
for Jesse McCartney so we're down to our
super 8 what's happening next week next
week we are back to the SmackDown rounds
well I believe see half of the
performers next week compete it out and
again another mass singer will be
eliminated and of course you can count
on Charlie and me to bring you this
little dose of fun you know amid all the
crazy stuff going on in the world again
we read all your comments we love
talking to you on Instagram and on
Twitter so please keep all those coming
and our promise to you that we'll be
here every single week rehashing this
crazy weird show that we love so much
I'm b29 I'm Charlie O'Keefe
[Music]